اعلن وزير العدل الامريكيه سماح بتحويل
اموال روسيه مصادره ومجمده الى وزاره
الخارجيه التي قال انها ستخصصها لدعم
الشعب الاوكراني والاعاده اعمار اوكرانيا
وفي حين قال الاتحاد الاوروبي انه على وشك
فرض عقوبات جديده على موسكو واستخدام
اصولا تابعه لها لمساعدتكييف قررت روسيا
ما وصفته بتامين ممتلكات واصول مئات
الاوكرانيين في القرن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي ابعاد واهميه
تحويل الولايات المتحده لاصول ماليه روسيه
مجمده لصالح دعم اوكرانيا في هذه المرحله
التي وصلت اليها الحرب بين موسكو
وبالتزامن مع تصعيد واشنطن ودول الغربيه
دعمها العسكري للاوكرانيين وكيف تلقت
روسيا القرار الامريكي وماذا بوسعها فعله
للرد على الخطوه الامريكيه في وقت توعد
فيه الكريملين بمرحله غير مسبوقه في اداره
موسكو لحربها ضد كيف والى اين يتجه مسار
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا في ضوء هذه
المستجدات وكيف تنعكس الخطوه على مستقبل
العلاقه بين الغرب وموسكو بالنظر لكونها
الاولى من نوعها في تاريخ التعاملات
الماليه
[موسيقى]
ان تصادر الولايات المتحده اموالا الروسيه
وتقوم بتجميدها فتلك خطوه سبق لواشنطن ان
قامت بها من قبل اما ان تقوم بتحويلها
واستخدامها فسابقه جاءت بها تطورات
وتداعيات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ذاك ما
اعلن عنه وزير العدل الامريكي تماشيا مع
السلطه الجديده التي منحها الكونجرس
لوزاره العدل والتي تتيح لها نقل بعض
الاصول المصادره واستخدامها لصالح اعاده
الاعمار في اوكرانيا نتابع ما اعلن عنه
وزير العدل الامريكي
اعلنوا انني اجزت اول عمليه نقل اصول
روسيه المصادره لاستخدامها لصالح اوكرانيا
وكان صدر اعلان مني في ابريل الماضي بعد
لائحه اتهام بحق الثري الروسي النافذ
قسطنطين بتهمه خرق العقوبات حينها اعلنت
ايضا مصادره ملايين الدولارات من حساب
مؤسسه ماليه امريكيه مصدرها عمليه التهرب
من العقوبات وامرت محكمه في نيويورك
بمصادره الاموال صالح الولايات المتحده
وبتفويض مني ستحول هذه الاموال الى
الخارجيه لتستخدم في اطار دعم الشعب
الاوكراني
المدعي العام الاوكراني اكد ان الاصول
الروسيه التي سيتم نقلها ستستخدم لصالح
جهود اعاده الاعمار
نشهد اليوم التصديق على تحويل اصول مصادره
بقيمه خمسه ملايين الف دولار الى وزاره
الخارجيه لاستخدامها لصالح اعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا التي دمرتها الحرب جزء مهم من
المساءله يتمثل بان يدفع الطرف المسؤول
ثمن الدمار الذي تسبب به لذلك فان التعويض
عن الاضرار البشريه والماديه الهائله التي
لحقت باوكرانيا يشكل جانبا مهما في اطار
سعينا للعداله هذه رساله واضحه ولن تكون
هناك حصانه او افلات من العقاب
بالتزامني مع هذه الاجراءات اعلنت روسيا
بدورها تميمه 500 من الممتلكات والاصول
المملوكه خصوصا لاثرياء قيل انهم قريبون
من السلطه والبنوك الاوكرانيه وقالت
السلطات الروسيه انه سيتم استخدام جزء من
اموال تلك الممتلكات والاصول لتمويل
التدخل العسكري في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
النقاش في هذا الموضوع معنا من موسكو
الدكتور
الباحث في شؤون الاقتصاديه والعلاقات
الدوليه ومن واشنطن دكتور دونال
الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه سابق في موسكو
مرحبا بكما سيد
دونالد ما هي المقتضيات التي دفعت
الولايات المتحده للقيام بهذه الخطوه بعد
مرور عام على الحرب وبعد فتره ايضا لا باس
بها من تجميد الاصول الروسيه
والتهديد والتلويح بمثل هذه العمليه الان
تقوم بها لماذا
يجب ان نشير الى عمليه بالغه التعقيد
فمجموعه العقوبات التي اشرتم اليها انطلقت
منذ سنوات ولكن كان هناك الكثير من
الامثله عن تهرب من العقوبات مع الكثير من
العراقيل القانونيه لوضع اليد على هذه
الاصول وتجميدها والان البيت الابيض
يستفيد من قدرتي على الضغط على الاقتصاد
الروسي كم سيستغرق ذلك هذا صعب لان
العراقيل القانونيه كثيره مره اخرى هذا
يعكس المسار العام للحرب يمكن لروسيا ان
تتعدى ويرد الغرب من ثم يرد الغرب بطريقته
يجب ان ننظر الى ذلك على انها حرب
تتبلور ومسار يتبلور والغرب يحاول الرد
على تهديدات روسيا واعتداءاتها ومؤخرا
راينا الك الدول مثلا تحاول التهرب من
العقوبات اذا يمكننا ان نتحدث عن جهود
متعدده
المستويات ويجب ان ننظر الى ذلك على انها
عمليه تراكميه يتم الاعلان عنها واحيانا
لا تتم متابعتها وهذا ما يجري هنا
هل تراه ايضا هو مسار يفتح مسار جديد يفتح
لهذه الحرب بعد المسارات الاخرى المسار
العسكري ومسار الدعم المالي وايضا مسار
العقوبات الامريكيه هو ضمن هذه المسارات
التي تتلاحق في الحرب
في كليه تاكيد نحن نتحدث عن مسار جديد في
هذا الوضع حتى الاجراءات السابقه التي
اتخذتها البلدان الغربيه لم تكن فعاله حيث
انها كانت تحاول ان تغير في السلوك الروسي
وهي الان تقوم بمصادره هذه الاموال
وتحويلها لدعم اوكرانيا اعتقد ان النقطه
مهمه اكثر بكثير في السياق الابعد من
العلاقه بين روسيا والغرب تغيرت قواعد
اللعبه بشكل كبير لان الدول الاخرى فهمت
الان انا يمكنها ان تكون ضحيه الضغط
الغربي الضغط الغربي الاقتصادي على سبيل
المثال الاصول الصينيه الوصول العربيه
الاصول الافريقيه او اصول دول في امريكا
اللاتينيه يمكن ان تصادر وتستعمل من قبل
الامريكيين والاوروبيين لاسباب في مخيلتهم
والمهم كذلك هو اننا نرى تدميرا لوصولي
وقواعد اللعبه في عالم التجاره الدوليه
كما كانت قائمه في الصادق ولا اتفاجا اذا
ما راينا بعد اشهر او بعد سنوات هذه
الاجراءات التي تعرضت لها روسيا تطبق على
بلدان اخرى هذه البلدان لربما تحاول ان
تنقل الاصول الخاصه بها الى خارج البلدان
الاوروبيه والامريكيه
انظر الى
بالتالي الى مسار الوسائل والتكتيكات التي
سيجري الذهاب اليها على ضوء التطورات
الميدانيه وعلى ضوء ما يجري في القرم
والتلويح باستخدام مجددا الاسلحه النوويه
واستهداف القرن من قبل الاوكرانيين وتزويد
الاسلحه الغربيه هل باتت كل التكتيكات
مفتوحه في هذه الحرب يضاف اليها هذا
التكتيك المالي الجديد
انا اعارض الى حد ما هذا التفسير اعتقد
مساله العقوبات انطلقت في العام 2014 و15
وكانت مستوى اخر
ممارسات الضغط الغربيه ضد روسيا
واعتداءاته هناك جوانب اخرى احد هذا
كرتونه وهو الاستمرار في الدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا اذا نقطه تستوقفنا حيث ان الجبه
قد استقرت عند حد معين راينا الجيش الروسي
قدم اداء سيئا وصار الان يستهدف اهدافا
اوكرانيه مدنيه بينما اوكرانيا تحصل على
المزيد من الاسلحه للتصدي للمزيد من
الوجود الروسي وتقدم الروسي لاسيما في
الشرق اوكرانيا ماذا تحصل بعد ذلك لا نعرف
ولكن الطرفين يلعبان لعبه مختلفه كذلك فان
اضيف هنا
لا يريدان الدخول في النزاع استراتيجي
اكثر من ذلك لكن الاشهر المقبله لسما
الشهرين المقبلين سيكونان
حاسيمين حيث ان روسيا تكبدت الكثير من
الخسائر تريد ان تدافع عن نفسها واوكرانيا
سوف تستخدم
اذا الاسلحه المتقدمه وسوف نرى كيف
او الى ما سيؤدي ذلك الشهران المقبلان
سيكونان اساسيين في مسار الحرب كيف تنظر
الى مثلا الفرضيه الاولى القائله هناك
فرضيتين الاولى تتحدث عن ان الطرف الغربي
لازال يمسك زمام المبادرة وبامكانه الحسم
وايقاع الاله في الطرف المقابل روسيا او
يعني هي حيله العاجز الذي لم يعد يستطيع
ان يذهب اكثر مما ذهب اليه من اجراءات ان
كان عسكريه او دعم او تصعيد
فيه تشيك اللوك اذا ما عايننا الحرب
الاقتصاديه اعتقد ان التدابير الاهم التي
يمكن ان تتخذها البلدان الغربيه قد اتخذت
على سبيل المثال الدول الغربيه فرضت حصارا
على معظم السلع الروسيه بما في ذلك في
مجال الطاقه هناك طرق تسمح باستحداث
اجراءات وتدابير جديده مرتبطه
بالاسمده الزراعيه المعادن لربما القمح
ولكن بشكل عام اهم التدابير والاجراءات قد
اتخذت لذلك ارى ان دول الغربيه لم يعد
لديها اي خيارات متاحه من المنظور
الاقتصادي الاقتصاد الروسي لا يزال قائما
وهناك تعاملات تجاريه بين روسيا ودول في
الشرق الاوسط وفي اسيا وفي افريقيا وفي
امريكا الجنوبيه لا يمكننا
تدمير الاقتصاد الروسي هذا المنطق اما من
وجهه النظر العسكريه يعتقد ان الدول
الغربيه قامت بالكثير ما الذي سوف تفعله
الان سوف تزود اوكرانيا بطائرات مقاتله
على سبيل المثال ولكن المضادات الروسيه هي
فعاله للغايه وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان من شان
ذلك ان يغير اللعبه العسكريه هناك حرب
استنزاف تجري الان ولكن دعونا ننتظر لنرى
العديد في الجيش الاوكراني اوكرانيا تحاول
ان تدفع تقريبا بكل شعبها للانخراط في
الجيش هناك صور نشرت
لرجال اجبروا على دخول في القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه وبالتالي اوكرانيا ليس لديها
ما يكفي من بشر لكي يكونوا في اعداد
القوات المسلحه وبالتالي بعد اشهر اذا ما
فشلت العمليه الاوكرانيه على اوكرانيا ان
تقر بان المازق العسكري قد وصلت اليه
ويتعين عليها ان تتفاوض ربما بعد اشهر
نتوقف الان عند بعض المعطيات التفصيليه
المتعلقه بالممتلكات والاصول الروسيه
المجمده وحده العمل التابعه للحلفاء
الغربيين المسؤولين عن تعقب الاصول
العائده للنخب الروسيه تؤكد ان الحلفاء
الغربيين جمدوا 30 مليار دولار من الاصول
المملوكه للاثرياء او النخب وحده العمل
تلك اضافت ان نحو 300 مليار دولار للبنك
الروسي المركزي الروسي المشموله بالتجميد
وقالت وحده العمل الغربيه انه تم الحجز
على عقارات مملوكه او يسيطر عليها رعايه
روس وفرضت عليهم عقوبات جدير بالذكر ان
بريطانيا قامت بتجميد اصول تزيد قيمتها
على 20 مليار دولار مملوكه للاوليجارش
وافراد اخرين وشركات سيد دونالد بهذا
الاجراء ان كان الان امريكيا
وربما ايضا تلويح اوروبي بالذهاب اليه
وايضا هناك رد فعل من قبل روسيا
ايضا على هذا الامر بتجميد اصول ونقل
ممتلكات لاوكرانيين في القرن للدوله
الروسيه يطرح بشكل مهم مشروعيه وقانونيه
مثل هذا التحرك وفقا للقانون الدولي
اولا شكرا على هذا السؤال الواجهه يجب ان
نفكك ابعاد هذه المشكله من الاسهل ان نجمد
اصول النخب اثريه الروسيه الكثير منها
جرميه اصلا في روسيا بسبب كل الدمار الذي
اتت به عليها ايضا
واجب اخلاقي ان تدفع مقابل الضرر الذي
تسببت به ولكن الهدف الرئيسي او الثمره
الرئيسيه هي ان كافه هذه الاصول هي اصول
المصرف الروسيه المركزي هذا هو الهدف
الرئيسي بالنسبه للنخب الثريه الروسيه
وبحسب القانون الغربي يجب ان نظهر ادله
على ارتكاب جريمه اما بالنسبه الى وصول
البنك المركزي فهذا غير ضروري لان اجتياح
روسيا
اذا ادانته الوان متحده وكافه الدول
وثالثا روسيا انتهكت القانون الدولي اذا
هذا يتيح لاضواء الغربيه ان تجمدها اصول
البنك المركزي الروسي
ولكن نتحدث عن هذه الاصول التي تاتي من
دول مختلفه وكل دوله عليها ان تتحرك وهذا
عمليه صعبه ان ندفعها جميعها الى السير في
الاتجاه الصحيح لهذا سوف نرى ان هذه
العمليه سوف لن تحصل سريعا سجمه راخوفيتش
بالمقابل عندما اعلنت روسيا بانها سترد عن
طريق ايضا مصادره اموال وممتلكات
لاوكرانيه مقربين من السلطات في كييف هي
موجوده في القرم هي تقوم بذات الخطوه ولكن
ماذا عن محدوديه مساحه التحرك الروسي ضمن
ملف الماليه ملف العقوبات ومصادره الاموال
وتجميدها ونقلها هو محدود بالنسبه لروسيا
هذا التحرك مقارنه مع الغرب
في نهايه المطاف يمكن ان نصل الى وضعيه
تكون فيها اصول الشركات الغربيه مجمده او
تخضع للتاميم واذا ما قمنا بتعداد كلي
الشركات خصوصا الشركات الاوروبيه التي
استثمرت في السابق في روسيا يمكننا
نرى ان الاموال يمكن ان تصل الى حدود 300
مليار دولار امريكي تقريبا نفس
قيمه الاصول التي جمدت في الولايات
القضائيه الغربيه على سبيل المثال
المعروفه لديها اصول ضفطيه في الروسي وهي
طبعا لديها عشرين بالمئه من اصول الشركه
الروسيه هذه لم تصادر هي لا تزال تابعه
للمستثمرين البريطانيين تتال على سبيل
المثال توتال اناجي لديها اصول في روسيا
هذه شركه فرنسيه وهناك شركات ايطاليه
واوروبيه اخرى اعتقد ان هناك طرق للتوصل
الى تفاهمات ولكن اذا ما سرقت الاموال
الروسيه بشكل كامل وحولت لاوكرانيا لا
نتفاجا اذا ما شاهدنا ان السلطات الروسيه
قد صادرت الاصول الغربيه وسوف يكون ذلك
درس المهم
الدول الغربيه الاخرى من يمكنه ان يقدم
الضمانات للصين او للعرب او
الافريقيين بان اصول هذه البلدان لن تجمد
في الغرب هذا ما يدمر الاقتصادات الغربيه
برايك يا سيد الى اي درجه ستؤثر مثل هذه
التحركات الامريكيه وربما
يعني وضع الاصول للدول في البنوك
الامريكيه مستقبلا طالما تستخدم هذه
الوسيله كعقاب لاي دوله لا تريد او لا
تعجبها الولايات المتحده تصرفاتها بشكل من
الاشكال سياسيا مثلا او عسكريا
سؤال وجيه ومشروع ربما
ولكنني اوكد هذا لن يؤثر ان الفرق بين
الاعتداء الروسي وسلوك الجرمي الدولي من
جهه والاموال الكبيره التي يمتلكها وما
تمتلك دول اخرى كبير جدا اعتقد ان روسيا
لديها مشكله مع الغرب ونرى انه عاده حين
يتصرف الغير فهو يمشي بحسب القانون وحكم
القانون
والمحاكم ومسار قانوني لا احد
الا ويعرف ما هي ممارسات النظام الروسي
المجرمه
وكذلك ممارسات مسؤولين الروس والنخب
الروسيه اثريه وهذا سوف يستمر هدف فعلا لا
يشجع المستثمرين من افريقيا او اسيا حين
يرون الممارسات الروسيه
طبعا الكثير لا يزالون يستثمرون في الغرب
ويعرفون ان اصولهم سوف يضمنها حكم القانون
دعونا لا ننسى ان النقاش حول الاصول
الروسيه في الغرب مرتبطون
بالسلوك الروسي واجتياح روسيا لدوله اخرى
وهذا ادانته الوان المتحده هذا امر يختلف
من حيث السلوك عن الدوله ربما تدخل في
نزاع مع بروكسل او واشنطن الفرق كبير من
حيث الجوده وليس او النوعيه وليس الكميه
سيد
بالنظر الى مثل هذا التصعيد ما فرص يعني
وقف هذه الحرب وعلى الاقل عدم اتساعها
لتذهب اكثر مما ذهبت اليه باستخدام المزيد
من الاسلحه الناريه وايضا الاسلحه الماليه
اشهر متعدده رئيس الاركان في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه جنرال الملي قال ان
اوكرانيا وصلت الى وضع ان حصلت فيه على كل
ما كان بالامكان على المستوى العسكري
وبالتالي
من المرجح ان تبدا المفاوضات اعتقد ان
اوكرانيا اذا ما فشلت في الجنوب وفي اماكن
اخرى بعد اشهر مما لا شك فيه ان الحاجه
سوف تبرز لاطلاق عجله المفاوضات وللاقرار
بان روسيا لديها ممر بري نحو شبه جزيره
القرم ويجب الاعتراف بالحدود الجديده
اوكرانيا يتعين عليها في نهايه المطاف ان
تصل الى هذا الاستنتاج ليس لديها ما يكفي
من عديد لا يمكنها ان تعمل على تعبئه
الشعب الاوكراني الشعب الاوكراني هو عباره
عن 22 مليون شخص 22 مليون نسمه لا تكفي
لشني حربا ضد امه من مئه واربعين مليون
واكثر وحتى مع المساعده الغربيه العسكريه
شكرا لك اشكرك يجب ان نتوقف عند هذه
النقطه شكرا لك من موسكو الدكتور
الباحث في الشؤون الاقتصاديه والعلاقات
الدوليه ومن واشنطن ايضا الدكتور دونالد
جينسن الدبلوماسي الامريكيه السابق في
موسكو شكرا جزيلا لكما هنا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]